with more than 500 million copies sold
worldwide Harry Potter is the
best-selling book series in the world
this is why Potterheads couldn't wait to
see a spinoff written by JK Rowling with
the new fantastic beasts movie series
and they will be even happier to see
their favorite characters once again
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know how the golden trio could
appear in the movie even if their
characters are not born yet if you love
Harry Potter as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up to see more
stories like this today we're showing
you 10 Harry Potter characters that
could be back in fantastic beasts Albus
Dumbledore Warner Brothers already
confirmed that Albus Dumbledore was
going to be part of fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald and he is going to
be played by Jude Law you probably
already know that he used to be Geller
its greatest friend when they were young
but they got into a fight that killed
Albus his sister and they didn't want to
talk to each other again
now that Grindelwald is looking for
wizard domination over muggles
Dumbledore is known as the only one who
can stop him he will defeat him in 1945
but we still don't know how Nicholas
Flamel when people found out that the
second fantastic beasts movie was going
to take place in Paris many fans thought
that we could meet one of the greatest
French wizards even though no one has
seen his face yet Warner Brothers
confirmed that we are going to see
Nicholas Flamel played by brontosaurus
key this character was mentioned in
Harry Potter in the Philosopher's Stone
when Voldemort tried to steal the elixir
of life to become immortal if you
remember the first movie you also know
that he was mentioned on Dumbledore's
chocolate frog card as the to work
together on alchemy but the
Philosopher's Stone has already been
created so what could they be working on
well Grendel wall try to steal it just
like Voldemort did Tom Riddle Tom Riddle
was born in 1926 which is the year when
the first fantastic beasts movie was set
and will graduate from Hogwarts in 1945
which corresponds to the last movie in a
series of five these two years are too
perfect so we think that it can't be a
coincidence as one of the main
characters Dumbledore will work at
Hogwarts as a teacher it is totally
possible that we hear about the young
wizard who will later become Voldemort
moreover JK Rowling confirmed that
Grindelwald was a seer and we wouldn't
be surprised if he saw Tom Riddle in one
of the
visions we think that Voldemort just
needs to be part of the fantastic beast
series Rubeus Hagrid and here is our
favorite half giant if you remember
Harry Potter in the Chamber of Secrets
you know that he used to study at
Hogwarts when Tom Riddle was there the
Dark Lord released a basilisk in the
school and put the blame on Hagrid when
a muggle born was killed because he was
friends with Aragog the giant spider but
some people knew that Newt Scamander was
actually responsible for that after all
Rubeus said that he got the egg from a
mysterious traveler which fits perfectly
newts description but their love for
magical creatures is not the only thing
they share they were both expelled from
Hogwarts because of this passion even
though they were not responsible Hagrid
totally fits in this story Nagini the
snake when Warner Brothers revealed who
was going to be a part of the second
fantastic beasts movie a mysterious
unnamed character played by claudia kim
caught our attention the only thing we
know about her is that she is a
maledictis the carrier of a blood curse
that Destin's her to transform into a
beast she also works at a circus where
the main attraction is the enchanted
snake girl and we think that it could be
her moreover fans think that she might
be the heir of Slytherin as the snake
will always be part of their family
these are just some of the reasons why
many people think that she will turn out
to be Voldemort's female snake Nagini
Ariana Dumbledore in fantastic beasts
and where to find them we heard more
about an obscure eel that turns into an
obscurest just like Creedence it is
described as a young wizard who
represses his magic powers and this
energy develops into an uncontrollable
obscurus many fans agree that we will
finally understand what happened to
Alice's sister Ariana in the fantastic
beasts series that's because she is
probably an obscure eel after all she
tried to repress her powers after being
attacked by young muggles since that day
she has never been the same and
Aberforth even described her as
explosive many fans think that
Grindelwald tried to use Ariana just
like he used Creedence we hope that
we'll hear more about that in the movies
Minerva McGonagall this is not the most
popular theory yet but we actually have
some proof that Professor McGonagall
might be part of the fantastic beasts
series after all she was teaching at
Hogwarts at that time just like Albus
Dumbledore they really got to know each
other when Minerva was heartbroken when
she
learn that a man that she loved married
someone else and confidences were
exchanged we bet that they were talking
about Gellert Grindelwald Minerva is
also the one who convinced Albus to
finally confront and defeat the Dark
Wizard Grindelwald which makes her an
important hero in this story we really
hope that we'll have the chance to see
this conversation in the fantastic B
series Gellert Grindelwald we do know
that the Dark Wizard is going to be part
of the movie series led by Johnny Depp
but we need to better understand his
role in the Harry Potter series to know
what's going to happen after being
expelled from durmstrang Gellert met
Albus and they became best friends both
looking for wizard dominant over muggles
for the greater good they were both
looking for the Deathly Hallows until
they got into a fight we know that
Gellar already has the Elder Wand in the
second fantastic beast movie and this is
where his story starts we can't wait to
see the most famous duel in the
Wizarding World Newt Scamander so it's
no surprise that Newt Scamander played
by Eddie Redmayne is going to be part of
the fantastic beasts series but did you
know that we actually heard about him in
the Harry Potter series in Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban
he appeared on the marauders map for a
moment we don't know what he was doing
at Hogwarts but some people think that
he asked Dumbledore to write the
introduction to his book fantastic
beasts and where to find them is
actually a textbook that students used
at Hogwarts and Harry Potter even wrote
in one of them we are really happy to
see that someone from Hufflepuff finally
get the attention that he deserves the
golden trio you're probably asking
yourself how the golden trio is ever
going to come back as they weren't born
at that time
but JK Rowling might have found the
solution she said that they could all
put on heavy makeup and laugh at a bar
in the background our goal would be to
spot them so the three actors won't be
back in their characters but it would
still be fun to see them Emma Watson
even confirmed that she would definitely
be up for a cameo in the Fantastic bees
series and you who would you like to see
in the movies don't be shy to answer in
the comment section down below
we love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 Harry Potter characters
that could be back in fantastic beasts
from
more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 disturbing real stories behind
Disney fairy tales thanks for watching